Hello everybody,
I'M HOME *Cue "Space is Cool"*
YAHHHH!!!
I'M FINALLY BACK HOME!!!
Oh man you guys dont know how long its been for me trying to get back here
You don't know what an arduous journey it has been
I mean, I love Bob and I'm so glad I was able to visit him in D.C.
But MY GAWD
Getting here has been has been a fffffffricking nightmare
So I'm home, yes.
So I'm finally gonna be able to play, "No Man's Sky"
Which is a game I've been looking forward to for a while
And I actually saw Bob play it, back when I was over visiting him
And we got it like- it was like midnight during the launch date
And we just opened it up and it was just like
<3 Mark Fangirls <3 ["So Cool" Counter: 1]
So like  this whole game is just  gonna be me going
<3 Mark MEGA Fangirls <3 ["So Cool" Counter: 2]
So yeah, look forward to a lot of that
That's gonna happen
So anyways I have not played it for myself
But I got a basic understanding of it because of what I gathered from um uhhh Bob here
And what your gonna see here is my kind of unedited journey into the world of "No Man's Sky"
And the point of "No Man's Sky" If I were to glean any sort of meaning
From what it is
The point is to represent, like, the feeling...the-the immense like unimaginable
Magnitude of the cosmos like I don't know I haven't read any reviews about the game
I haven't really read up on any of the meta of the game
Or the lore of the game or anything like that
But just from what I saw
From Bob playing
It's about this gloriously huge...
IMMENSELY ENORMOUS...(dick jokes)
*Sound of computer interrupting quietly*
...Universe with which you are dropped into
Procedurally generated from start to finish
Ok?
I'm on f-fff Feigheso-Nik Isdik
*giggle* Sounds like the space core
Ohh
I'm so excited
ohhhh man
repair required, ok.
So I got the basic premise of the beginning of this game
uh
ok
thank you
I got a jet pack
So what I am going to be showing you guys is kind of
Ok. Good
At least we have that
So basically you're stranded on a planet(robot voice rudely interrupts Mark's sentence)
Ok
Planet
Feigheso-Nik Is-Dick
heheh is-dick
Good thing I am on planet is dick
or else I wouldn't have a good time while I'm here
But you're stranded on a planet and you have to use your like multi-tool to try to
find your way back into space,
which is the first objective, and probably what I am going to do in this episode here, but
right here,
something very interesting,
cuz
Reality seems to fold in on itself.
One moment I can see debris, in another a vast red orb,
almost too large and too bright to behold.
It knows me, inside and out, more than I ever could know myself.
Could this be the face of creation itself?
Or in my hazy freshly-awakend state
am I being manipulated?
A name burns itself into my mind:
Atlas.
And a request made without words
that I should follow the path this being
This Atlas has set for me.
You know, uhh what's interesting about this is
Bob chose
to spurn the direction and explore freely
Which will be totally fine
But... from what I've gathered
There is an idea that
there is something
at the center of the universe
And I believe this thing will set you on a path to go there,
and that's kinda what I want. I don't know if I am ever even gonna get to the center of the universe
I don't even know if that's a thing that's possible
Because the universe in this game is so unbelievably big
Much like our universe is so unfathomably big
That I kinda want to accept it's guidance for now
Or not... There we go.
I feel suffused with the warm glow of approval.
I was lost, but now am found.
The Atlas acknowledges my allegiance
Oh shit, did I just allegizice myself to something?
ok
So what ever that did I'm not 100% sure
but it sets you on a path that might be
going to the center of the universe
and so
you have your laser here
BRRRWAMMM
and you just gotta destroy
the planet
to gather
crap
uh, like carbon and stuff
that you need to be able to get back home
and you used these base things
uh, for iron and such
such as you get things that you need
and your mining laser can overheat
oh, find your crashed starship
well I know where my crashed starship is
it's right there
how can anyone-
oh shit, my scanners damaged
-how could anyone uh, miss it
Can I run??
woah
What was that??
oh, ok
alright then
Helllooooo :)
ruazumama
aight
Thrusters critically damaged
Vital launch and landing gear system
ok
So I need to get enough materials to be able to
repair these things for this
You need 4 carite sheets, uh which
you craft here
But I don't have enough because
they require more iron
so basically the beginning phase of this
just gonna be a lot of uh,
gathering materials and also exploring this planet
because this planet
is completely unique
to every other planet in the universe
Or maybe not completely unique
You might find similar planets
But every procedurally generated
Right down to the plants
Right down to the animals
It's like the Spore creature creator
There's worlds out there that have horrifying
Dick monsters
I guarantee it
Im like that guy from Mens  Warehouse
I guarantee there's some planets
Or many planets with dick monsters
of completely varying size, shape, and girth
*while laughing* so if you want to look forward to something like that
Then that's what you get
Also I need zinc and heridum
Theres a bunch of stuff that i need
and I'm going to go get it eventually
But for right now I'm just gonna explore
uh the baser things here
So there's like Cargo drops
That you can get
ohh
I don't know what that is
I don't know why that is
Atlas pass, i don't know what that is either
nothing found
well thank you for that
ahhh plutonium
good, exactly what I needed
nothing!
great, I'm so glad these useful
drops, were put here
for me
ok, thats broken
what is this?
Deflection Enhancement Tau..?
ok
for the starship
man, that needs a lot of materials
I don't have any of that
But there's something over here
how do i run??
wooah
Please tell me that wasn't run
ok whatever
huggheeeeeeee
puthu
ok
some people will probably be upset that they didn't
complete the job on that one
You've learned the Vy'keen word for 'interloper'
now the Vy'keen thing is instresting
the Vyy'keen thing not viking thing
and also the plants have the silicate stuff
and all that jazz
God damn it
Is it the field of view like turn up really high??
am I zoomed in on something?
Or am i just looking really closely at everything on the screen
I dunno
it seems like everything
a lot closer than it was
hugheeeeee
ok, so that's nothing
how about this
phfttughaaa
I don't know have a scanner yet
I need to get enough materials to be able to
be able to scan something
But that comes later
*hhhhrrrg*
is this gonna zap everything on the planet..
Eventually I'll get down to the core and blow up
the entire existence of where ever the hell we are
on is dick
planet is dick, ok
Hello! Hi!
Who are you??
Can I help you???
Are you a friend?
uhhhhh
ok bye
thank you
Did you just sterilize me or something?
Did you shoot me with gamma las-lasers??
ok, torch
ok so there's
uhhhhh, let's see
how do I repair things?
options??
nooooo..?
oh, waypoint's discovered
I don't know... I don't know
Oh man, see im in a system too
Like I'm in a solar system,
so, my specific star has a certain number of planets in it
so there maybe be other planets in this system
But i wouldn't know that until i get up into space
which I'm so eager to do causes it's so cool  ["So Cool" Counter: 3]
now i don't know about the longevity of this game
but right now, it's so cooool  ["So Cool" Counter: 4]
*mark fangirling about how cool it is.*
Ugh I can't imagine it!
I'm sorry!
Im not even in space yet and I'm freaking out about it
Its just that, i know that there are a lot of games
that are going to be coming out are supposed to be like this
and recent space
There's like this one, ah man I forget the names of them
Im, um terrible with names
But theres a couple of games
That area supposed to be about space exploration
and all that stuff
and this is- the first one that has come out thus far
uh, but there's more on the way
and I don't know what each of them is going to be
but the fact that there's more space games
coming out, is just ughhhhhh
It tickles my soul
I wanna go to space so badly
Alright, but I'll be there in a second. Also, um...
Okay, so I Think I have enough to be able to...
...Oh..
I'm sorry, can I help you?
What're you doing?
Okay, so I need to...
...how the frick do I...
what is...
Can you go away, please? Okay
That's not it- tha- oh, here we go, Controls. That's what I needed
Okay, so...
*Markiplier listing out controls*
Inventory, thats right I need to press on
Big do daddy button so, hang on
Boink
Alright, that's what I needed
so, I need to go to my exo suit
and i need to repair
the exo suit???
no, my tool. no I need to repair this
Which I have
there we go
So now I got- my scanner and my analysis visor
So the analysis visor is whats gonna help me, uh
oh
nooo??
is whats gonna help me scan different things in the environment
by uh, there we go
What is that??
YESSS
Aibilum Auralitasum
ok?! Cool.
I don't know what that do
oOOOOOohhHHH
Boink!
Odefortera Cigeratium
oh *giggles*
then you just analyze things
*while laughing* Kumforia
*still laughing* Kumforia?!?!?
oh ok. Sure!
Im ok with that
oh man, ohh.
Why is the screen like cut off on the sides for me???
I think, i think whats wrong is..
Ohhh, thats why
Cause I was zoomed in, never mind
Im freaking out about absolutely nothing over here
*euchhhhhhh*
I need your delicious carbon
Excuse you??
*weird moan noise*
The hell was that?
There's also animals
On these planets
On the planets that are capable
Hello?   *weird bird nose*
Birbs???
On the planets that are capable of- of
Cool, Thamium9. On the plants that are capable of
uh, harvesting life
There are animals, and there all procedurally generated
I don't think i'll be lucky enough to spawn on the...
*more weird bird noises*
Holy shit.
Good god, what is going on out there?!
uhh
ok
Also.. Yeaahh thats how you launch
uh, I don't think there's any running but
definitely
uhh some stuff here..
Did I get- uh I already gathered these, ok so
what i need to do is I need to-
- uh what I need to go out and i need to go find
more rare minerals and there's something
STOP MOANING IN MY EAR
Why did i have to get the planet of the moans?!??!
cause everyone's moaning about planet is dick
alright
eh
so anyway, oh wait hang on
i need to scan this
How do i scan?? There we go
oOOOOOooo look at you
Why do you move??
Hizone! Gipsourage-ge
*more markipler noises that are hard to translate*
sorry buddy
you seemed like you could move, which probably
meant your some sort of intelligent
But not intelligent enough to get away from my laser
And also my mining beam is out of charge
so what i need to do, is i need to..
Zip Zap my zippy-
*weird noise that scared(?) mark*
oookk?
The hell is going- What're you doing??
What are you?? Ima scan you
Are you something that I should blow up??
I mean Bob blew it up but this one doesn't seem
to be attacking me very much
So i'm just gonna operate under the assumption that you're peaceful
And that everything is total fine
ok, so
over here.. I saw something
No??
uh man, apparently not
Oh god this is gonna take forever to destroy
ah I'll go after the easier targets
And I'll take these- like these small cactus  like things
They just blow up- I hate the way they shake
before they blow up
*while laughing* NO PLEASE. OH GOD
and then kaboom
and then they're gone forever
oh jeez, hello
What is you?
Analyzing
Oph-Ophoaeum
Um--umllumberium
I think they're just making shit up now
I'm pretty sure
I don't know what the intelligence for- HELLLoooOO
WHAT ARE YOU??
OH
Junt- ah it's temperament is shy
come back here Junounpoli Gophelnat
oh hoo, your too cute!!
Don't run from me...
...even though I'm a big, terrifying monster- look at you!
*squees at the extraterrestrial cuteness*
Aw look at you!! :))
Aw you're too cute! :)
Aw I'm gonna name you.
Just give me a second- I need to name ya
I need to name ya, like individually
Because when you discover things because everthing's randomly generation
You have the right to name them
Which is kinda cool, wow it is cold as shit
How did it get so cold?!
And what the hell am i supposed to do about that??
Can i do anything about it being cold??
ok so, these big- for some reason
There's big piles of gold out on the surface
I don't know why, I don't know why there be
Man, but why is it so *weird noises
Night here is terrifying
apparently
God damn it, what's with the- there must be
more animals searching around
but i don't have time to let it bother me
I have to get this gold and get going
Cuz you gotta get materials of all sorts to be able to
do the things that you need to do.
And pretty much everything can be destroyed
And I don't know-
Like, I don't know what kind of planet I would land on where there'd just be a giant stack of gold jutting out from the ground and then my fir-
*Ominous noise*
My first instinct is to blast it with a laser away
but then again I don't know what sort international economy
is going on here, because
the Vy'keen
once we'll get into space you'll see like,
Me- me  and bob when we were first
jettison into space like, i didn't see
much pass out but it was just
*mark fangirling about how cool*
HOOOO OH MY GAWD
and then there- pla- there were uh, ships up there
and then, then he died
and it was really stupid because he picked a fight
with someone that he shouldn't have picked a fight with
Annnd that was his fault because he's dumb
And also not very smart
But me,
Im equally as dumb
So i imagine that I'm gonna make similar mistakes and good god it is cold
WOooAAhh
What are you?
ooo hello
oooo
Abject Gophelnat???
That's a good name for you.
congratulations on being well named first off
i don't have to kill you now
woah, hello.
ah, oo what is that?
oo there's something down there
huuughh
Is it like a cargo deposit?
something like that- oW my ankles *laughs*
Why did that happen?
I guess you're not supposed to fall from great height..
Is that plutonium?